I'm now heading back into the state of
Assam I'm awaiting with Julie it's an
island in the middle of the Brahmaputra
River where fish is plentiful and the
locals make an amazing fish curry
but first I'm stopping off enjoy at
there's an event going on today by some
crazy lady who's attempting to stick
over sixty chilies in the mouth within
two minutes and eat them and then she
wants to go on and rub more in her eyes
can we make this on the way to module II
we won't miss the ferry I've got to see
it yeah okay
I mean is she nuts unreal let's go more
chillies are eaten in the northeast of
India than anywhere else in the world
and as Sam produces the hottest on earth
[Music]
mum of one a man DITA tamale has a
massive appetite for them today
she's attempted to break her own world
record for 1860 hot chilies in two
minutes
yeah this is no ordinary chili Anindita
we'll be munching on the boot Jolokia
yeah the whole thing won't eat it he's
taking them to have a bite but not to
eat it not to chew it okay hot this baby
is 200 times hotter than a jalapeno it's
a chili nuclear bomb that's very hot
why doesn't know very very hot indeed my
mouth's still burning on a little piece
of one are you mad
okay good luck here we go I'm playing
safe by being timekeeper three two one
go
ten seconds gone Oh
[Applause]
excuse me two minutes
there's stop oh Jesus soon be sick get
some water for the lady quickly oh my
god come he's dead 17:19 here so she's
49 Suzy level off the record
unfortunately 49 okay don't cry don't
cry don't get upset over a chilly down
but not out
anindita has decided to up the ante
she's going to try to rub more than 12
chilies in her eyes in under one minute
come he's that thirty ready three two
one go
[Music]
fifteen seconds gone come on you gotta
wake up
thirty seconds gone
[Music]
we study help you Percy 24 she had
broken the record she's broken
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks and congratulations for them
really well done I think you are mad
hope you know nonetheless it works
excellent I mean those chilies were
extraordinary hot I mean unbelievably
hot just biting into one it just sort of
exploded all said your mouth went on
fire but it's a very bizarre thing to
witness she's all for Troy I confirmed
nut